this morning the FBI and federal
prosecutors are investigating two men
close to president Trump's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani the former New
York mayor's financial dealings with two
clients are in the spotlight
after prosecutors say those men tried to
flee the country Wednesday Lev poorness
and Igor Froman helped Giuliani dig up
dirt on Joe Biden and his son hunter
varnas and Froman were charged yesterday
with funneling foreign money some of it
from Russia to a super PAC that supports
the president's re-election that's a
violation of federal law Paula Reed is
with us now Paula could these charges
hurt the president well the White House
is already under pressure from an
impeachment inquiry and this raises
questions about the president's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani but the president
says he doesn't know these men and the
indictment does not accuse him of any
wrongdoing but at a rally last night in
Minneapolis these ongoing investigations
were clearly on the president's mind
let's impeach the president right I
don't think so
at his first rally since the impeachment
inquiry began President Trump
angrily railed against Democrats these
people are sick I'm telling you they're
sick and escalated his rhetoric against
former Vice President Joe Biden he was
only a good vice president because he
understood how to kiss
Barack Obama's and his attacks came
after two men who helped his personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani investigate the
Biden's were arrested US Nationals Lev
Parnas and Igor Froman were charged with
illegally funneling foreign donations to
political campaigns including three
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
to a pro Trump super PAC defendants
broke the law to gain political
influence House Democrats have also
subpoenaed the men as part of their
impeachment inquiry the pair is seen in
pictures with President Trump and
Giuliani as well as Donald Trump jr. I
don't know those gentlemen you know it's
possible I have a picture with him
because I have a picture with everybody
but can't wait to come back but CBS News
has learned harness and FRU men did play
a key part in linking Giuliani with
Ukrainian contacts you did ask Ukraine
to look into Joe Biden of course I did
just hours before their arrest the two
men had lunch with Giuliani their former
attorney at the Trump Hotel in
Washington Brendan Fischer of the
campaign Legal Center first raised
partisan Truman's campaign finance
violations to the FEC last year these
two were central in bringing the the
narrative about Biden and Ukraine to
Trump's inner circle the same Ukraine
narrative that President Trump espoused
in his call with President Solinsky
prosecutors say partners and fruit men
also lobbied a Republican lawmaker to
have the former US ambassador to Ukraine
were called after Giuliani expressed
frustration that she was blocking his
efforts to investigate the Biden's the
ambassador was eventually recalled and
that's just one of the incidents causing
upheaval at the State Department where
yesterday Mike Pompeo senior advisor
resigned a lot going on those pictures
of Rudy Giuliani and the two men look
like they were all having a really good
time yes they may be having less of a
good time nice to cop yes thank you very
much